No voy a sorprender a nadie, pero
en términos económicos las últimas
3 décadas han estado dominadas sobre todo por
dos conceptos íntimamente vinculados entre sí:
Por supuesto estoy hablando de, uno, la
globalización y, dos, la deslocalización.
Todos, absolutamente todos
conocemos, y seguramente,
además, bastante bien, estos dos
fenómenos económicos y políticos.
(Por un lado, durante los últimos 40-50 años
las fronteras del mundo se han diluido. De
repente las mercancías, los capitales y las
personas se pusieron a viajar frenéticamente
a lo largo y ancho de todo el mundo.
Las restricciones cada vez eran menos.
Por otro lado, las grandes multinacionales
trasladaron gran parte de su producción,
habitualmente los procesos menos complejos,
a países con mano de obra más barata y
regulaciones más cómodas. Ahora a través
de una enorme, interminable y complejísima
cadena logística los productos que llegan
al mercado, por ejemplo un smartphone,
suelen estar hecho con piezas, componentes y
tecnologías de un montón de países distintos.)
Pero si hablamos de la globalización y de la
deslocalización tenemos que hablar necesariamente
de un país. Un país que ha explotado esta
nueva realidad económica como ningún otro:
estoy, por supuesto, hablando de la conocida como
la fábrica del mundo, la República Popular China.
Y motivos no faltan, cerca del 30% de toda la
producción industrial del planeta tierra pasa,
precisamente, por este país. China
se ha convertido en una gigantesca
potencia económica e industrial
gracias a este sistema económico.
Durante años y años, las multinacionales del
mundo se han instalado en el gigante asiático,
tanto para producir como para intentar
hacerse hueco en su descomunal mercado
con casi 1.400 millones de
consumidores potenciales.
Sin embargo, stop, un momento, porque ahora
este proceso se está frenando en seco.
Las tensiones comerciales entre China y
Estados Unidos no han parado de crecer
en los últimos años y la llegada de Trump a
la Casa Blanca marcó un antes y un después.
(En febrero del 2018 la potencia norteamericana
comenzó una guerra comercial que supuso que para
diciembre del 2019 cerca de 250 mil millones de
bienes de producción china pasaron a estar sujetos
a un arancel del 25%. Unos aranceles que ahora
la Administración Biden ha decidido mantener…
Al tiempo que ha introducido nuevas restricciones
al comercio tecnológico con el gigante asiático.)
Las cosas van de mal en peor. Las imágenes de Xi
Jinping estrechando lazos con Vladimir Putin o
las constantes amenazas sobre Taiwán han sido
algo así como la gota que ha colmado el vaso.
N1 (Las tensiones en Taiwán obligan a las
multinacionales a replantearse
el riesgo de China. Expansion)
Queridos amigos, amigas, si la globalización echó
abajo muros fronterizos, pero ahora
estos están volviendo a emerger.
Y ni siquiera hablamos únicamente
de China. Gracias a la economía
globalizada países como Corea del
Sur o Taiwán, entre otros muchos,
también se han convertido en proveedores
absolutamente claves para occidente.
En el caso de Taiwán por ejemplo, hablamos de
una isla dónde se producen los semiconductores
más avanzados del mundo. Chips absolutamente
necesarios para las empresas tecnológicas y
militares de Estados Unidos. Desde
Apple hasta la Lockheed Martin,
porque por si no lo sabíais Taiwán,
o mejor dicho, la industria de
chips de Taiwán juega un papel importante
en la producción de equipos como el F-35.
Pero, entonces… ¿Qué podría ocurrir si, por
ejemplo, un buen día Pekín decide bloquear Taiwán?
¿Y si China finalmente decidiera invadir la isla?
¿Qué ocurriría con las cadenas de suministro?
Y, además, si algo así se produce o, simplemente
las tensiones entre China y Estados Unidos siguen
creciendo…. ¿Cómo tendrían que reaccionar
las multinacionales? ¿Qué pasaría con el
riesgo geopolítico o con, simplemente, con el
riesgo reputacional? ¿Deberían abandonar China?
C1 ("Se está pensando mucho en las
posibles alternativas hasta llegar a:
'¿Qué haremos en caso de que haya
una guerra? ¿Debemos cerrar nuestras
operaciones en China? ¿Cómo podemos mantener
nuestro negocio y superar posibles bloqueos?",
Jörg Wuttke, director de la Cámara
de Comercio de la UE en China.)
Es evidente, la invasión rusa de Ucrania lo
ha cambiado todo. Ha sido por así decirlo,
toda una bomba de relojería. Lo que
antes se consideraba impensable ahora
se percibe como posible e, incluso, como probable.
Ahora en medio de su primera gran crisis desde
1978, la China de Xi Jinping empieza a ser un
país incwómodo para los inversores
y las multinacionales. Y por eso,
aunque no pueden abandonar semejante mercado,
cada vez son más las compañías que se están
planteando seriamente trasladar parte
de su producción fuera de China.
Y de hecho, desde el inicio de la guerra
comercial, este país ha perdido cerca de
4 puntos en su cuota de mercado en las
importaciones de Estados Unidos. Para
que os hagáis una idea, esto supone
cerca de 117 mil millones de dólares.
Y no solo eso, frente a la deslocalización
tradicional ahora se ha puesto de moda
otro concepto: el nearshoring, esto es,
deslocalizarse pero cerca de casa, a ser
posible a países vecinos. ¿El problema? Pues,
precisamente, la falta de alternativas viables.
Sin embargo, para las empresas norteamericanas
hay un país con mucha mano de obra, salarios
relativamente reducidos - incluso por debajo de
China - y una garantía total para los suministros.
¿Sabéis de qué país estoy hablando exactamente? 3,
2,1…. Exacto… Por supuesto,
estoy hablando de México.
T1 (LA DÉCADA MEXICANA)
Pese a todos los problemas - que no son
precisamente pocos - como la violencia,
el narcotráfico o la corrupción generalizada,
lo cierto es que la economía mexicana ha
mejorado mucho. Y no ha sido algo fortuito.
Todo comenzó en 1965, cuando
se puso en marcha el conocido
como Programa de Industrialización de la Frontera.
(Este plan permitía que empresas extranjeras
orientadas a la exportación se instalarán en
parques industriales mexicanos y pudieran
operar desde ellos con ciertos beneficios,
por ejemplo no tener que pagar aranceles
para la importación de suministros.
Fueron las llamadas maquiladoras, el embrión
del potentísimo tejido industrial que hoy
encontramos en México. Allí nació,
por ejemplo, la apuesta mexicana por
la industria del automóvil que hoy genera más
de 2 millones de empleos, que se dice pronto.
De hecho hoy el superávit comercial de
la industria automotriz es mayor que
el excedente que México obtiene por el comercio
de petróleo, el turismo y las remesas. Fijaos.)
Pero más allá del plan de 1965,
encontramos otros dos momentos clave,
los dos grandes puntos de inflexión de la economía
mexicana que, además, fueron casi consecutivos.
El primero de ellos tuvo lugar a
comienzos de la década de los 80,
cuándo el país decidió dejar atrás el
proteccionismo y apostar por un nuevo
modelo económico. Desde entonces este
país se ha convertido en uno de los más
globalizados del mundo. Ha firmado acuerdos
de libre comercio con más de 40 países.
Precisamente, uno de ellos y el segundo gran punto
de inflexión, fue, por supuesto, el acuerdo de
libre comercio con Estados Unidos y Canadá. Este
acuerdo entró en vigor en 1994… Y desde entonces,
las exportaciones mexicanas han pasado de
representar el 12% del PIB al entorno del 40%.
Hoy México es un importantísimo productor
de automóviles, piezas aeroespaciales y
dispositivos médicos. Empresas como General
Motors, Boeing, Bombardier, Kia, Lego o Rolls
Royce - la de los motores de aviones - entre otras
muchas ya tienen enormes factorías en este país.
Y, ojo, que hablamos ni más ni menos que del sexto
mayor productor de tecnología de todo el mundo y
la tercera economía que más inversión extranjera
recibe en el sector aeroespacial. Poca broma.
Fijaos cómo han cambiado las cosas:
Por supuesto, las relaciones con la economía
estadounidense es la gran protagonista de toda
esta historia. Para que os hagáis una idea,
el comercio bilateral entre Estados Unidos
y México ha crecido a una tasa media anual
de más del 8% durante los últimos 28 años.
Y ojo porque lejos de frenarse, esta dinámica
parece cobrar cada vez más y más velocidad. En
2022 las exportaciones mexicanas al norte de la
frontera se estima que crecieron cerca de un 20%
Sí, muchas veces en Estados Unidos
se habla de la frontera sur como
un gran problema. Sin embargo siempre se
olvida su característica más importante:
Cada minuto, 1 millón de dólares de productos
comerciales atraviesa esta frontera en un sentido
u otro. Insisto cada cada minuto. Hablamos de
casi 1.500 millones de dólares diarios. ¡De locos!
(Muchas grandes empresas de Estados Unidos
se instalan en México para hacer algo muy
similar a lo que otras hacen en China.
Esencialmente el esquema es el siguiente:
Los diseños y los componentes más avanzados los
importan de Estados Unidos y de países como Japón,
Taiwán o Corea del Sur. Luego en México
terminan de dar forma al producto,
lo ensamblan y más tarde lo exportan
de vuelta al vecino del norte.)
Esa es básicamente la idea
inicial, claro que luego,
con el paso del tiempo muchas empresas comienzan a
realizar también actividades mucho más complejas.
Y eso explica porque este país es, precisamente,
el segundo gran proveedor de Estados
Unidos tan sólo por detrás de China.
Y, ojo, porque ni siquiera está tan lejos.
Mientras que el peso de China en las
importaciones de Estados Unidos se ha reducido
del 27 al entorno del 22%, el de México se ha
mantenido estable en el entorno del 16-17%. En
otras palabras, que se habla mucho de China,
pero México es casi tan importante para los
Estados Unidos como el gigante asiático.
¿Sorprendido? Pues, queridos amigos, amigas,
echad el freno, porque lo mejor
podría estar aún por llegar.
¿Recordáis lo que hemos dicho de
la crisis de la globalización y
de la nueva moda del nearshoring? Pues
bien… Aquí México se lleva la palma.
Para la industria de Estados Unidos
este país tiene muchísimas ventajas:
por ejemplo es una enorme fuente de mano
de obra relativamente joven y preparada,
tiene fáciles conexiones por carretera y
ferrocarril, un acceso comercial privilegiado
y para colmo los costes laborales medios
ya son más bajos que en la mismísima China.
Sí, sí, me habéis escuchado perfectamente. Fijaos.
Además, a parte de la frontera de Estados Unidos,
México tiene salida tanto al Océano Pacífico
como al Océano Atlántico. Esto quiere decir
que tiene una posición privilegiada ya que
puedo importar fácilmente componentes de Asia,
de Estados Unidos o de Europa al mismo tiempo.
Y aún más. ¿Sabíais qué México es el octavo
país del mundo que más ingenieros gradúa cada
año? ¿Sabías que enviar un contenedor
de México a Nueva York lleva menos de
5 días mientras que enviarlo desde Hong
Kong o Shanghai puede suponer hasta 40?
Es decir, que si le damos una
vuelta, México parece con mucha
diferencia en el destino predilecto para la
producción de las compañías norteamericanas.
Ahora bien, ¿Qué implicaciones puede tener
realmente la moda del nearshoring para México?
¿Realmente podemos decir que estamos ante
toda una oportunidad o no es más que uno
de esos conceptos que se ponen de moda pero que a
la hora de la verdad apenas tienen consecuencias?
Pues… ¿Queréis un dato? En 2021,
los inversores estadounidenses pusieron
ya más dinero en México que en China.
Además según estimaciones del Bank Of
America, si México apuesta por este proceso,
sus exportaciones podrían crecer un 30%
durante los próximos años. Hablamos de
más de 150 mil millones de dólares
de nuevas exportaciones cada año.
Por supuesto eso supondría millones de empleos y
muchísima riqueza… Que ahora están al alcance de
la mano. Xi Jinping ha creado una enorme grieta
de la que ahora México puede aprovecharse.
Claro que un momento, porque
no todo es tan bonito.
México parece estar a las puertas de una
nueva era dorada… Si se hac en bien las
cosas podríamos llegar a hablar, incluso,
de la década mexicana. Ahora la economía de
este país podría fácilmente crecer por
encima del 5 o incluso el 6% cada año.
Sin embargo… También es posible que la oportunidad
se termine perdiendo o no se
le saque el máximo provecho.
¿Y sabéis qué? Mucho ojo, porque eso es
exactamente lo que podría ocurrir. Atentos.
T2 (CON AMLO HEMOS TOPADO)
Las ventajas de la economía mexicana parecen muy
claras. Sin embargo, luego a la hora de la verdad
las cosas no parecen carburar tan bien, o al
menos no tan bien como sería lógico esperar.
Por ejemplo, desde que diera comienzo la guerra
comercial entre Estados Unidos y China la cuota
de mercado de México en las importaciones
de Estados Unidos apenas cambió. La caída de
China fue capitalizada fundamentalmente
por otros países asiáticos. Fijaos.
("La mayoría de las ganancias han ido a
Asean, India y Corea. Al menos por ahora,
los datos de penetración de las importaciones
de EE. UU. no apoyan la opinión de que México
ha sido un beneficiario neto del
nearshoring". Informe de UBS)
Y no solo eso. Desde 2015 la inversión en capital
fijo, esto es máquinas, fábricas, edificios,
establecimiento, etcétera, etcétera, dejó de
crecer y desde 2019 para colmo se ha reducido.
Para colmo su economía en los últimos años ha sido
una de las menos dinámicas de toda América Latina.
Así que, digámoslo muy claro: esto
supone un gran fracaso político.
El mayor impedimento para que México desarrolle
todo su potencial como alternativa
a China puede ser el propio México.
El presidente es hostil a la
inversión extranjera, de hecho,
una de sus primeras decisiones paso por cerrar
ProMéxico, una agencia gubernamental dedicada
a promover la inversión en el país. No la
reformó y la puso deberes, no, la cerró.
Luego las infraestructuras tienen
enormes carencias pero aún así
el gobierno mira para otro lado y
dedicó buena parte de la inversión
pública a proyectos de tan dudosa
rentabilidad como el tren maya.
Y por supuesto, titulares como
estos no ayudan nada de nada.
N2 (12 de junio de 2022: México
apunta a las empresas privadas,
amenazando décadas de crecimiento económico. WSJ)
N3(14 de enero de 2023: El giro de México a la
autocracia debería preocupar
a los Estados Unidos. WSJ)
¿Queréis un ejemplo concreto? AMLO
tiene entre ceja y ceja recuperar
el control estatal sobre los sectores
del petróleo, el gas y la electricidad.
Para ello no ha dudado en cerrar centrales
eléctricas privadas con dudosos motivos,
bloquear terminales de importación
de combustibles en los puertos,
suspender las nuevas subastas
de exploración de hidrocarburos,
paralizar las nuevas inversiones privadas en
el sector eléctrico o, incluso, sacar adelante
una ley que obliga a la red eléctrica a dar
prioridad a la electricidad producida por CFE,
la eléctrica del estado, a pesar de que
su energía es más costosa y contaminante.
Eso, por ejemplo, hace que la
electricidad en México sea un 40%
más cara que en Estados Unidos. Una clara
desventaja para las empresas industriales.
¿Otro ejemplo? Pues… Atentos.
N4 (México nacionaliza el litio
en el impulso del presidente
populista para extender el control estatal. FT)
Esto amenaza el único proyecto
significativo de Litio que había en México.
Y, ¿qué queréis que os diga? Son solo
algunos ejemplos de lo que es una
dinámica demasiado habitual. A AMLO
no le gustan las multinacionales ni
la inversión extranjera. Así que se
dedica a poner palos en las ruedas.
(Hablamos de una actitud que hizo
que varios senadores de Estados
Unidos llegarán a pedirle al Presidente
Biden que tomara medidas inmediatas
contra lo que consideraban una “agresión” al
acuerdo de libre comercio de norteamérica.
El problema es que todas estas políticas
y la enorme incertidumbre regulatoria que
está alimentando AMLO puede hacer que el
país pierda una oportunidad histórica. De
momento que el crecimiento sea débil o que
la emigración de mexicanos a Estados Unidos
se haya acelerado por primera vez en más
de 10 años no parecen buenos resultados.)
Con todo, quedémonos con la parte más
positiva. México parece tenerlo casi todo para
convertirse en uno de los brazos industriales
y tecnológicos de las economías occidentales.
Hoy por hoy los parques industriales
del norte del país están llenos y cada
vez más empresas se preguntan si sus
próximas inversiones no tendrían que
dirigirse precisamente al país del tequila,
los tacos, los mariachis y el verano eterno.
Si México hace las cosas
bien, reduce la incertidumbre,
mejora sus infraestructuras y favorece la
inversión extranjera, la próxima década
podría tener como gran protagonista mundial
al mayor país hispano de todo el planeta..
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno para
ti: ¿Creés que México aprovechará esta
oportunidad? ¿Será está la década mexicana?
¿Qué crees que tiene que hacer el gobierno
mexicano para impulsar este proceso? Déjanos tu
respuesta en los comentarios y abramos debate.
Ahora si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle a like
y suscribiros a VisualPolitik si
es que aún no lo habéis hecho.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.